thank you very much
I would like to thank very warmly the
Prime Minister IDI Rama and his
magnificent Hospitality this Summit is a
historic Summit it is truly a summit
that is making history writing history
it's the first time that this Summit
takes place in the western Balkans
region it's the first time that the list
of the European Union and the leaders
from the Western Bowl concert are at the
same table this follows The Summit in
Bordeaux and also the meeting that was
held a couple of months ago the summit
and that took place in July and Brussels
so we have today a statement declaration
it is a really important statement
because it also contains some concrete
commitments that are additional to the
accession processor
and so I would like to repeat uh
the the following I think that the
future of our children will be safer and
better with the Western Balkan countries
being a part of the European Union and I
think that this integration process is
key
uh
both sides will need to do a number of
things so in order for this process to
happen there is the Improvement of the
rule of law fight against corruption
Improvement of the G3 Etc that any
progress needs to be made on these
fronts and the uh on the side of the
European Union we also need to commit
further to the countries of the western
Balkans the agreement that has been
found for roaming is uh one step forward
after the meeting of Bordeaux which gave
rise to this idea and this will allow as
of 2023 and certainly before 2027 I will
lead to
the decrease and possibly the
suppression of the cost linked to
roaming this will be extremely
beneficial for the companies for the
inhabitants of the western Balkans and
it will also favor tourism
a further commitments are
being made in order to counter the
negative consequences of the war of
aggression of Russia against
the Ukraine and to fight the
consequences in terms of
food safety Financial package
the negative effects of this war
launched by Russia against Ukraine and
finally I would like to say a few words
about migration we know that migration
is always a sensitive and difficult
topic and difficult Challenge and we
know that the recent weeks recent months
we face again
difficulties and an increase of the
numbers and that's why this concrete and
operational cooperation with Western
badges is fundamental for all of us and
I would like to explain my gratitude
because with some days we were able to
make some progress by aligning the Visa
policy which is a concrete step in the
right direction we know that some
additional decisions will be needed in
the following days and weeks but we are
optimistic and confident it will be able
to make some progress and to manage
together this situation
as you can see
but this Summit was really a key Summit
and I would once again thank Eddie
hammer and I would also thank our
partners from the Western ball cancer
during this meeting this meeting showed
that there's a high level of respect and
of trust of course we are aware that we
are in difficult times
climate change digital
change and then the war in Ukraine that
is a changing Shifting the whole
political geopolitical landscape so we
needed to work for
freedoms in tomorrow's world we need to
fight for our values that is enforcing
our choices and so it is great news that
there wasn't one concern the European
Union are looking for through a shared
future a future of shared values
hmm
okay in respect of
the foreign journalists here I'm going
to speak in English to make it easier
also because it's very difficult to
translate me from Albanian to English
I want to thank again wholeheartedly
Sean Michelle
the president of the European
Council and the dear friend I should say
but first and foremost a really loyal
committed Friends of the region and I
can say it because
I've seen him fighting for the region
and in this I want to join
Ursula
the president of the European commission
another big well-known Fighter for this
region and as I said in our plenary
we never had
we never had at least I don't recall
another president of the council and the
commission who
has been like Charles and Ursula so
resoluted to advocate
for the region to push
for the region and to
make sure that the process which we know
it's very difficult in itself
does not die
in agony and this being said I want to
underline the very historical dimension
of this Summit is the first time ever
that European
the European Union gets out of the
borders of EU
to have a summit and this happens in uh
the Western Balkans and namely in
Albania I see it as
an amazing
an amazing sign
of an awareness
first of all
that nowadays
the European Union needs the Western
Balkan as much as the Western Balkan
need the European Union
and on the other hand I see it also as
an appreciation
for our country
for its role in the region as a
resilient and committed factor of peace
stability
and cooperation
and I want to believe also
because
it's the moment to
send to all the people in the region but
first and foremost to the Albanian
people
that the European Union is
here for us
he's here for you
because it's a well-known fact
the Oracle of Brussels the EU barometer
has stressed more than once that
albanians are the most
pro-eu nation in Europe
not because we are naive but because we
come from a
very very real Health not
from the French hell which is a paradise
French people called hell but from real
hell of isolation
and of total impossibility to connect
with Europe
and we had our difficult moments we had
our frustrations we had our sufferings
but we never ever gave up
on this faith the faith on the European
Union and of course this is a summit
this is a gathering this is a step this
is not uh we end
of uh our our way towards European Union
but this is a milestone in the same time
which shows not only by the present but
also also by certain facts I'm sure that
the president of commission will will
detail them but I want to tell today to
the students and to the youngsters in
our country
that uh from this Summit we come out
with a great news that not only our
universities will be able to to to to to
engage with their residence plus but
they'll be included in the alliance of
higher education in Europe and from
certain moments after of course all the
procedures needed will be will be done
our
students
our kids
can study from here in every European
University in in a digital way and our
universities can start to make alliances
and to grow together with European
University this is something that until
now
was possible only while you become a
member
as the other thing about the green the
green Lanes with Croatia with Italy with
Greece this is also something
new and great for transportation and for
trade
also the
the other fantastic
thing that we have discussed uh we got
the support in principle both of the
presidential Council and the president
commission and as far as I understood
the full support also of
the leaders to push for heavy in Tirana
the European College of Bruges campus
it's an it's a it's a very highly uh
replicated uh University
uh that has had its first campus in
Poland in 1992 to support the Eastern uh
communist former communist countries to
get into you and now it's time to settle
this campus in Tirana it's fantastic
uh not less roaming agreement
so our citizens here and there will be
able soon to have tariffs that are much
lower and will enter in the network of
the European
citizens
and to end with the most important
energy
we already got from
the European Union through the
commission
budget support
for the next year
85 million euro but in the same time
there is another package
for projects and we already have our
projects and the region will be all
involved in this uh in this path to
build more sources of energy
and to
get
more distance from the Russian influence
so I would I could talk
much longer but I want to stop here I
told also
the European European friends that we
are hosts today and uh
I told them that in our canoe in our
first written code
the house of Albanian belonged to gods
and the guests
but guess what today we had guests that
in Albania
they are considered gods
the gods of the Europe Union
and I told them that the code is very
clear you have to be prepared to give
your life for your guests so we were
when we are still ready they are not
they are still here uh God forbid
something happened but then we are ready
to give our life so uh never ever I'll
use this moment to complain or to
criticize or to say things that I can
say much easier when I'm in Brussels
and the very last I will remember one
thing from this Summit
a beautiful moment when we were in the
family photo
and I was listening
many of them
saying the sun the sun
a beautiful sun
so we succeeded after 10 days of
Brussels weather
to bring the sun this morning for them
so uh what can we do more
our life is in your disposal
Madam president please
he has to say because it's Brussels
thank you so much thank you thank you
very much and indeed Eddie
um it's an fantastic experience to be
here and you are outstanding hosts we
will I think never forget this family
photo and this fantastic performance
traditional Classics and the future the
modern part outstanding
um amazing to see that and thank you
very much for your words let me reassure
you that our support for the region
really comes from the bottom of our
heart
and because we are deeply convinced that
we belong together
you've said you would as host
be willing to give your life for us we
don't want your life we want to live our
lives together
and thank you very much for uh this this
outstanding Summit it was a summit where
there was a very clear message of unity
we want to tackle the issues that
problems the challenges we have together
a summit of partnership
with very deep very good Frank and
trustful discussions
and of course we have touched on many
topics I want to highlight a few
a big topic is of course that we want to
tackle the difficulties the knock-on
effects of this atrocious war that
Russia has Unleashed together and one of
the main topics is of course energy
for us it's important
that together with our friends from the
Western Balkan we address this energy
crisis together in a way that we mirror
whatever we do in the European Union
also in the western Balkans so for
example the fact that household and
business struggle as much in the western
Balkan as in the European Union for us
is important to give the similar
Solutions therefore this one billion
package of energy support which is split
in two parts it's 500 million direct
budget support which gives the
opportunity to support in a targeted
manner the vulnerable households and the
vulnerable businesses and the second
half
500 million euros in infrastructure to
make sure that we have the investment
already in the energy of the future and
the energy of the future is of course
renewable energy renewable energy is
cheaper it's affordable it's cleaner
better for our planet and it is
homegrown it provides good jobs here at
home so it gives Independence and
security of Supply
the investment of these 500 million will
go of course in Renewables in
interconnections so infrastructure but
also Energy Efficiency
yesterday we have approved six different
projects it goes from large-scale
photovolt type to solar District heating
from wind farms to the rehabilitation of
hydropower plants just to give you an
idea about that of course a strong
emphasis is also on Energy Efficiency so
to improve through additional investment
the situation of Hospital schools
University from an energy Energy
Efficiency standpoint to improve the
situation
Beyond energy of course this is a part
is the bigger frame of the economic and
investment plan you're all familiar with
it with investments in transport and
water and wastewater management digital
smart Labs just to name a few here too
we have just adopted yesterday 40
Flagship projects worth 1.8 billion
euros so the good news is also this
economic and investment plan is on track
my second Point
looks at the situation that we have
overall in the relationship between the
Western Balkan and the European Union
and let me reassure you that we are
full-heartedly supporting the
enlargement progress process and the
regional integration
this year has seen a lot of progress
we have had indeed the first
intergovernmental conference with
Albania and North Macedonia there is
finally New Movement momentum in the
whole process it was a historic step to
open the accession negotiations and now
the screening has started and the
momentum is there
we as a commission recommend granting
candidate status to Bosnia and
Herzegovina on the understanding that a
number of steps are taken now we are
very much looking forward to a decision
to be taken by the council
and there besides this progress that we
see there is of course the important
topic of the economic integration so the
common regional market
I really want to commend you for the
progress that you've done in the common
regional market in the last months it is
very good for the region that you have
signed agreements that underline the
importance of freedom to travel to study
to work it makes trade easier in the
region it creates new jobs so all these
are topics that are moving forward and
highlighted the importance of this
Summit to give it speed and acceleration
a third point that we discussed today
was migration
migration has long been a shared
challenge
we have a strong common interest
incorporating closely on all the aspects
it's a question of managing migration
together
and therefore yesterday the commission
has presented an action plan on the
western Balkans to strengthen our mutual
cooperation on that for me it is
important to convey again the message
you can count on our support to deal
with border management and to deal with
the migration and Asylum process we are
in this together and we have to manage
that topic together it is crucial for us
to move forward here at the same time we
expect all our Western Balkan Partners
to align swiftly with our Visa policy
this is also crucial to maintain to
maintain the visa-free regimes between
us because it is a question of mutual
respect of the rules
and indeed finally I also want to
emphasize the topics concerning Youth
and I know Eddie how much use
um is important for you the projects you
are we're the one who mentioned first to
me that you wanted more opportunities
created in the region for young people
and you were the one who asked us to
think about the possibility to opening
the European University's initiative to
all Western Balkan countries today we
can say we have delivered thank you very
much for starting this process the
Western Balkan universities will be able
to join the European University's
Network this means it enables students
from the Western Balkans not only to
study physically in the different
universities of Europe but also remotely
here in Tirana to have full access to
the European universities and in that is
your vision to have one day the College
of Europe here like in British like in
Poland and did full support also from my
side this is something where I hope that
in due time at one of the next Summits
we can say we deliver it thank you very
much
thank you madam president we'll take a
first few questions from Albanian media
yes please
Clan TV
the first question goes to both
presidents I do not know whether you
have managed
foreign
I do not know whether you have managed
to understand an element which
characterizes people in this part of the
western Balkans and that is that they
want to hear things clearly stated and
vociferously why did you pick Tirana was
it the reason because albanians are the
most pro-european because for instance
serbs are those who are more pro-russian
for instance and the question to prime
minister Rama there's a second package
for the entire Western Balkans and for
Albania do we have any figures how much
Albania will benefit and what types of
projects do you aim to support with the
support of the European Union thank you
maybe why do other in fact a few a few
weeks ago I had the occasion to uh to
propose to the prime minister to host
that meeting it was very important for
us to have this Summit by the end of the
year and we thought indeed that Tirana
and Albania was the the appropriate
location for hosting such a summit and I
would like again to to send you uh their
privacy their ID to send your team
because it was very impressive how it
was possible here in Albania in a
limited period of time to organize such
a summit it's not not easy we have this
experience in Brussels many times in
Brussels it requires a lot of efforts of
logistical attractions that need to be
to be solved and I think this is a very
strong signal not only for Albania for
Albania of course but this was the
decimal pins this is a very powerful
signal to the people of the western
Balkan because the the goal is not just
to have important tools with the leaders
the goal is also to send a powerful
signal to people in those in belgians we
absolutely convinced that our future is
together
perhaps the part that you asked 85
million is a direct budget support
within this 500 million package there
are quite a few different projects
um that are now being funded with the
other 500 million I think the six
projects that we approved yesterday are
120 million I know that some of the
projects are for example a large
photovolt type power plant here in
Albania but I do not know other projects
from the top of my head so perhaps we
can go more in detail with our staff
now the the Balkan way about why Tirana
would be because we are the best because
we are the oldest
and of course uh because uh we are the
law the most loyal but I I I I don't
think this and I didn't say this
I said I simply said that uh to them
that this is the best place to be for
you because it's the most pro-european
country in Europe based on EU barometer
not on my opinion
and I would add because Tirana is so
beautiful and uh uh if Mark Rooter
yesterday told to the Dutch press that
this is the most emotional adventure of
this year for the European Union imagine
now going
more soft
how beautiful it is
anyhow when it comes to the package I
would say that beyond what Ursula
already explained and that you know
there is another package which is based
on the projects and we have several
projects that we
are ready to apply for that uh one is
the pipeline that will connect here with
Laura
to make sure
the connection between uh the transfer
radic Pipeline and the Laura terminal
and the terminal power
that will be transformed in uh in uh
gas
and everyone today mentioned in the in
the in the plenary that the Balkans have
a big potential to become a real hub
to help the Central Europe
to get out of the Russian dependence and
of course Albania is part of the western
Balkans and of course Albania has an
important potential and is an important
role to play in this and I'm very happy
that this is a common understanding on
our side and on the European Union side
so we'll work together and of course as
you know
European union doesn't give money
and so I'll tell you okay take them
because you are the oldest you are the
best and uh we have love for you the
money are there we have to make the
right projects and to fulfill all the
criterias and then get the money so but
I am sure that we will be able to as we
have been able before we'll be able now
and not only us but all the all the
Western blogging countries because it
will go through the wbif right so this
is
thank you um yes from ABC News
thank you now that the Summit is over
and Brussels came to Tehran and enjoyed
our performances dances and Sun my
question is when will Tirana come to
Brussels when will Albania and the
region becomes a member because it seems
like Russia should increase its bombing
somewhere so that you can increase your
attention to the region thank you
I can I can start
um I would say
that
it's unfair to to say this
because the progress has been made
especially
in the last periods and by no doubt also
because of the war as an accelerator
is immense
is immense it was not 10 years ago
was
little time ago when we were in Brussels
and we had all these fights and we had
all this press conference and uh
Charlie didn't even show in press
conference and so on
and it's a totally different different
thing and let me conclude my part by
saying this
when it comes to the membership
we should do our homework
and I told them I tell always to
everyone
and I haven't changed my mind
before when I had my debates with some
of the European uh friends and leaders
about why we need the accession talks I
used to say we need to
have the tools of the accession
process
to
make ourselves stronger to make our
institution stronger to build our
systems to to get in the level of a EU
functioning
state
it's not the membership it's just
starting today I have the same opinion
we need to do the homework
so it's not about hiring but in the same
time
it what is happening is it is historic
because the European Union
is in the meantime creating spaces and
creating mechanisms of support that are
bringing us nearer
without waiting to be members
in the old way and the old way not of 30
years ago a few years ago
never we would have got in the alliance
of universities because to get in the
alliance of universities you need to be
European Union member
we are getting there now
why because there is a common
understanding that while we do the
homework we need to be supported and to
be more
uh more near
and near and near to get this Europe
together the roaming agreement would
never happen
if
uh this acceleration would not be
present the green Lanes all the things
that are happening are new things
it's a new
it's a new mindset and that's why I said
thanks to uh both presidents that are
here
and I have the honor to be here with
them uh things are changing and if you
remember when Ursula got the vote to be
president of commission she said
it's the birth of a jail political
Commission and this is what is happening
for the first time the Balkans are being
seen and treated like a jail political
strategic reason for the European Union
to think in depth
now when will be members one thing is
sure we albanians and Albania will be
loyal to the European Union even if the
European Union disappear will continue
to fight to be members even if we are
single member so it doesn't matter we
need to progress this is the most
important
and I would like to add that the U
doesn't intend to disappear exactly but
even we'll protect you from you but I
would like to say a few words
first of all let me uh um state that I
did not wait for this meeting to come to
Tirana I have had multiple exchanges of
you whether the Prime Minister Mr Rama
for the last three years uh since I have
been appointed as a president of the
European consulate but even before
these dialogues these exchanges of views
and these this improved understanding
that I have with Mr Rama but also with
other leaders in the region uh have
shown how important it is to ramp up a
number of processes and there were a
number of us who had already decided
that we needed to accelerate the
accession process of the western Balkans
and the war in Ukraine has proven this
even more
but facts are facts
a few months ago um we were in Brussels
you remember the press conferences where
uh Eddie Rama spoke
at the time in Brussels we were all
frustrated we expressed fatigue and
we let down and thanks to this meeting
in Brussels
thanks to the political commitment the
political will we managed to unblock
which was blocked in an unjustified
Manner and this is how we've managed to
relaunch the whole process
the list that we've made is not a
declaration of intention these are
concrete projects
which are the result of exchanges of
views that we've had even before the war
in Ukraine and I remember that
told me that we should not wait until
the end of the integration process to
see uh Progressive and concrete results
for the citizens so that citizens in our
countries understand how beneficial it
is to go for enlargement and I hope that
the Western Balkans will make progress
of course there will be a lot of work to
do but let me uh be very clear we
mentioned the energy package we
mentioned universities and the fact that
albanians will have increased
connections with European universities
the fact that the College of burrito
will open a subsidiary here in Tirana
these are concrete projects which will
concretely impacted the life of citizens
and our companies these are not generous
words we are happy to be here in tehrana
and we will come back very often and I
hope that Eddie Rama and the other
leaders will come to Brussels very often
Eddie it is true
that what we realize in these decisive
times because of the brutal war that
Russia Unleashed against a peaceful
neighbor a neighbor that only wanted to
determine how they see their future by
themselves
we see a very decisive time
and it is like a curtain that is being
raised and you look at the essence
of things
and the essence of our Union is that we
are a union of values
yes of course we are also a union of
prosperity
but fundamentally we are a union of
values
and yes I have the Deep impression that
in these decisive months
which are also transformative times for
the European Union
we feel in the western bulk and in the
European Union
this transformative movement forward but
we take the same direction of travel you
can see it in the economic integration
the way we address for example the
energy crisis that together we already
align right now in investing massively
in Renewables with the view that in a
future time hopefully very close future
we will be in one Union and use the same
renewable
infrastructure that we are building now
even more telling example is indeed uh
the uh Europe the universities of Europe
because nothing is more convincing than
young people
who are growing up in the same
educational environment
to build the next European Union Next
Generation European union and of course
sharing all the values and therefore
working for being one Union
and here I think indeed this atrocious
War has brought more speed more
acceleration and more momentum in the
whole soul
thank you
um Suzanne yes please political over
there Suzanne could you stand up Dave
yes um please
from Politico um it's a question for
president Michelle do you think there is
enough support for to Grant candidate
starters to Bosnia Herzegovina next week
we heard from the commission president
that this was proposed by the commission
but maybe you would update us on that no
I of course I don't want I don't want to
anticipate but there is a clear propose
on the table which is very good on the
other hand the ship agency is working
very hard in order to prepare the next
ministerial meeting the nutrition we are
supporting behind the scene all the
efforts that are that are needed but I
do not intend to anticipate in order to
to avoid making the tools more
compressible or more difficult I hope I
hope suddenly I hope that a good signal
will be will be given very very soon the
following days but let's see what will
be the decision to return at the
ministerial level and Mr Rama it's a
response to the attack on the the
apparent attack on the opposition a
leader just outside here in Tirana today
do you have a response to that well my
clear response is already ready out
since an hour
probably you know
the website of the
government thank you Philip
Philip lomonda
yeah I would like to talk about the
accession and talk about Kosovo
so five countries are still not
recognized and Kosovo and this morning
the president of Kosovo said that she
would like to
claim a file for accession so is that
possible and what future do you see
forecastable two points
so I can confirm the information
this information and the president of
Kosovo the has been gone public and then
it's going to be the Council of the
European Union who will have a true uh
look at that claim and to see what
follow-up is going to
[Music]